just a couple hours from the Iraqi
conflict zones it's this small slice of
the American Dream kurdistan's first
self-proclaimed
subdivision how much would one of these
houses cost cost as today it's around
250 to 300 thousand dollars Wow fall of
a million dollars yep cost meeting
between the land and the construction
cost Hammond is ie is occurred who
splits his time between Northern
Virginia and northern Iraq where he
founded American village just outside
the Kurdish capital of Erbil you can see
most of the developers like big
developers in the Gulf area even in in
Lebanon or in Turkey they start to move
to do business in the real estate here
desire in a European partner sank six
million dollars into this gated
community and received another ten
million dollars for water sewage and
electricity from a private lending arm
of the US government back then Iraq and
its sectarian bloodshed hardly
encouraged outside investment but in
recent years the oil economies helped
her bill and the surrounding area
developed supermarkets malls and
high-rises at an unprecedented rate
the oil company they are very important
to improve the Kurdistan economy most of
the projects in Erbil they've been
occupied by the staff member of family
members of these oil companies this is
also gonna create cash and business to
the area today many of the city's cranes
stand still and construction projects
have been placed on poles when ISIL they
decided to attack the Kurdish area this
is make the people worry about their
economic consideration so that people
start to not invest their money in real
estate in 2012 desire use most expensive
property sold for six hundred thousand
dollars local Kurds including several
government ministers snapped up
properties hoping to rent them to
families of oil workers from companies
like Gazprom the recent war on their
doorstep has left at least 10 homes here
unsellable and driven off around 70
percent of the communities expats what
happened when they are when they are
leaving
for last month's everything's being
slowed down the cafe here currently
caters to far fewer customers leaving
developers like dizzayyyyy
to debate kurdistan's future business
need some political stability to run so
they are actually stable and then we're
going to be boosting of the business in
the whole region but across this region
including Kurdistan stability may not
return for some time